- Man, you know my name
with two Rs!
- Ooh!
- Ohh!
- That should be a loss of point.
- That ain't no loss of point.
- Da-ron.
- It's still—Da-ron.
♪♪
- Avery Williamson, Darron Lee.
Speedy linebackers for the Jets.
And we're gonna kick their ass.
- What's up,
Best Football Friend?
- [Laughing]
- You see that? They're just taking it.
- I know. They know. They don't
know what to say right now.
- All talk, man. Y'all talk.
It's all good. It's all right.
- Yeah? You feelin' confident?
- Very.
- I like how he goes,
"Yeah, this is easy."
- Like, "I knew my own number in college."
- You got this.
- Don't say anything.
- On the count of three.
- Go ahead.
- Two, three.
- Ohh!
- [Groaning]
- One off!
- Dang!
- So close,
but yet it doesn't count.
- You're sleepin' on the couch.
- [Laughing]
- Damn.
- Oh, damn.
- You have no chance.
- I mean, none.
It's some stupid name.
- Yes.
- I'm going with his hometown
and putting a "Prep" on the end.
Holland Prep.
- No.
- Abington Friends?
It sounds like a TV show.
Damn. What'd you do last year?
- Oh.
- Hit Smokin' Jay.
- Damn.
- How can you not hit Jay Cutler?
- Ahh!
- Wow.
- Damn, what?!
- Damn, you had a bad year.
- Damn!
- But, see, a quarterback hit
is [$33,000].
- For hitting Jay Cutler.
- Actually—oh my God,
yeah
Both of them
were actually on Jay.
- Really?
- Both of them were on Jay.
- Are you kidding me? $66,000.
- That's a nice Mercedes
you just lost.
- Damn. I know, right?
- You'd have been better off
hittin' him with a Mercedes.
- Man.
- I do know this. Yeah.
Cuz he has a big mouth
And I heard him telling
everybody in the office.
- They saw it on my Instagram.
- Well, you know
I don't go there.
- [Ding]
- We got it right?
- Yeah.
- Childish Gambino.
- What's up?
- You ready? I'm ready.
- Ohh!
- Oh, that's different.
- What'd you have?
- "Best Looking"
and "Most Beautiful."
- That counts. That counts.
- That's the same!
- Apparently, I'm the only one
that believes in rules.
- That's the same.
Point, good guys.
- Wow.
So Nashville was havin'
a down year, huh?
- Right?
- Down year?
Oh, it was a very up year.
- Dude. Hold on a second.
- If he doesn't get this right—
- Oh my gosh.
- I am questioning everything.
- Hold on a second.
- We've gone through this
repeatedly.
-Seems like it's around here.
- [Buzzer]
- You seemed like a December guy.
- You seem like a former friend.
- Ohh!
- Wrong.
- [Imitating buzzer]
- He got it wrong.
- All right, you wanna know
what's even worse?
- Tell them.
- Is I asked him
what his birthday was
before we came in here.
- Yeah.
- Did you?
- We're like, "Just in case!"
- I go, "They might
ask me again."
♪♪
- [Laughing]
- This is so weird.
- This is weird.
This is uncomfortable.
[Whistle]
- Yep.
- You got it? You good?
- Yes, keep going.
- OK.
- No, other side.
- Other side?
- Yes.
- Damn. Damn.
- Yes, there it is.
- All right. Here we go.
- Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep.
- All right. Open up, buddy.
Ooh, that was a good one.
- All right. Put it down.
- Where is it?
- Mouthpiece in the middle.
- Yep, yep, yep.
- Yep. All right.
- No, other way, other way.
- Hold on, hold on.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Catch the ball.
- Ball! No.
- Water, water, water, water.
- Stay here!
- Ball!
- This isn't fair. Ready?
- Ball's coming!
- Catch the ball!
- No! What?!
- All right, I'm gonna tell ya.
I'm gonna tell ya.
Ball's coming.
Catch! Catch!
- Yeah!
- [Laughing]
I gave him good eye black.
- [Coughing]
- My hands were in your mouth.
But that's good. They're clean.
- My bad.
- You have to throw that
into the hoop.
Lefkoe's legs cannot move,
but his arms can.
- I'm nervous.
- I don't know where this is goin'.
All right. Here's the first one.
- Uh-oh.
- Uh-oh is right.
Uh-oh!
- Ohh! Ohh!
- Can't move.
- No, he moved!
- I moved my feet.
- That's all right.
- So you can't move your feet.
- Oh! Nicely done.
- I'm the Calvin Johnson
of hula-hoop planes.
- No.
- Oh, I found the touch!
Watch out!
♪♪
- Don't choke.
- Ohh.
- Damn, bro.
- Woo!
- Nobody comes into our house.
Boom. Four out of five. Woo!
- How you like that?
- It's all right.
- Best of luck. Good luck.
Way to find your touch.
- Thanks, man.
- You should probably do it.
You should probably do it.
- Oh, me?
- Cuz I got the longest arms.
- Oh, you're switchin'?
- Nice and easy.
- Oh, gosh.
- All that air.
- Oh!
- Ooh!
- Uno.
- Ohh!
- There you go. You got it now.
- We got it.
- Yes.
- Oh my God.
- That was it, wasn't it?
- Money.
- You're supposed to be
a meathead linebacker.
You're not supposed to
be able to do this.
- Ooh, he's gettin' cocky.
- One more.
- Game point. What's up?
- Right now it's tied.
- Are you kidding?
♪♪
- Let's go!
- Let's go! Let's go!
- I thought we had it locked up.
- Let's go!
- Ohh.
- Great job.
- Today's winners are
Avery Williamson and Darron Lee.
And as you can tell,
boy, are they humble.
- They are humble.
- Very humble.
♪♪